good morning Hank it's Friday it's
question Friday and the day that I
answer real questions from real
nerdfighters let's get right to it
favorite joke Billy was a chemist son
but Billy's no more what he thought was
h2o was h2so4 hey what's your take on
the Oxford comma lovely comma space
unintrusive comma space and absolutely
necessary can you cartwheel
oh no who the eff is Hank the Hank is a
city of just over 3,000 people in
southern South Dakota known for its
pheasant season do you fit into those
wooden shoes in the background kinda
other than Heights what are you afraid
of hmm
dese mice and Oblivion what did you an
egg fight about when you were kids we
primarily thought about whether I should
be able to rewrite the rules of games we
were playing while we were playing them
in order to ensure my victory I felt
that this was not only my privilege as
an older brother but also my
responsibility whereas hank was kind of
a wuss about it John how are you so cool
for a nerd I don't agree with your
premise and as evidence for my case I
would like to present you with middle
school me thanks for getting me those
glasses mom how can I find other
nerdfighters at my school my
recommendation is to acquire or make a
dftba shirt
what is the FEBA mean anyway it means
don't forget to be awesome
what would you name your puppy sized
elephant I would call him Luis and we
would be the best of friends how can I
get all these old nerdfighter jokes if
I'm a new nerdfighter if you listen
Hanks music read my books watch some old
videos and hang around for a while
you'll get it all eventually how do you
feel about the Kindle I don't really
care how people read I care if they read
is your next book really narrated by a
girl yes we ever read another book with
David Levithan maybe but in the meantime
you can just read David Levithan amazing
new book that he wrote by himself
the lovers dictionary link below
favorite mountain goat song Raskolnikov
felt sick but he couldn't say why when
he saw his face reflected in his victims
twinkling eye what mountain goats album
should I start with I forgive you for
ending your sentence with a preposition
and present you with a recommendation in
the doobly-doo will we ever see the Yeti
I don't know let me consult my edition
of Yeti research or volume 24 number 8
this thing has ads as a snowmobile ad I
guess that makes sense I mean if you're
gonna be finding the Yeti you might need
a snowmobile yeah no I don't think
you're ever gonna see the Yeti would you
date a girl more intelligent than
yourself yes in fact I married one your
head desk was lame that's not a question
but thank you for your constructive
criticism hold on I'll try to do better
ah oh-oh-oh
excessive head desk the rest of today's
video will be performed while concussed
is the world going to end in 2012 I
excessively head dust and now I don't
remember your question what is the
purpose of a water tower I used to know
the answer to that it involves gravity
but then I excessively head dust and
forgot what's your middle name
I don't know is today Tuesday did I hit
my head earlier how old are you why am I
sitting in front of a video camera when
will your zombie apocalypse novella be
finished hopefully within a week or so
it's terrible and I want to finish it so
I can go back to my real book but I need
some zombie killing scenarios so if you
know of any can you please leave them in
the doobly-doo Hank there are a bunch of
other questions but I think I actually
gave myself a concussion so ok I will
see you ah blue ball man that yeah
Monday I will see you on Monday